Freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
Video ich bin hier nicht alleine ich bin
mit Lukas und mit Randy den beiden Sushi
Experten auf Youtube Deutschland gerade
würde ich sagen ihr kommt aus Tokio
gerade wart ihr noch da von einer halben
Stunde ist Sushi Experte lass ich
überlasse es ihm die Jungs sind auf
jeden Fall unterwegs gewesen ihr kennt
die Serie wir haben bereits Burger und
Pizza Bewertungen erraten jetzt habe ich
die beiden Jungs an meiner Seite und wir
werden herausfinden welches Sushi
Restaurant welche Bewertung hat Erik
wird bei drei Restaurants bestellen eine
kleine Änderung auch ihr werdet nicht
sehen bei welchen Restaurants wir
bestellen so dass wir mit raten können
dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder wenn
die erste Bestellung da ist ich habe auf
jeden Fall Hunger mitgebracht sehr gut
so Leute die Bestellung ist da und Erika
hat uns die Bewertung aufgeschrieben
zeig mal her ich bin gespannt drei
verschiedene Bewertungen werden bei
wollte wieder bestellt das heißt sie
liegen zwischen 0 und 10 Uhr 7,4 das
bestimmt die schlechteste 8,2 und 9,4
nach sollte machbar sein insbesondere
Nummer eins sollte sich klar erkennen
lassen deswegen schauen wir uns das
ganze jetzt mal an ich finde dieses
komisch wie wir dieses Video drehen ist
es einfach komplette Psychose wir hatten
eigentlich was ganz anderes geplant die
Jungs waren in Köln scheint kommt vorbei
wir bestellen Sushi ich hoffe es macht
euch trotzdem Spaß ich glaube das ist
der Hauptgrund ist
[Musik]
okay Druck
in der Küche okay okay okay okay eric
hat bei allen Restaurants eine Sushi
Variation bestellt und das sieht schon
mal genau nach dem aus was ich gerade
brauche frittiert die müssen die
einzelnen bewerten also ich habe wir
müssen jetzt schon entscheiden welche
welche Nummer das sind genau vielleicht
können wir noch mal switchen müssen mal
gucken wie großzügig Eric dann mit uns
ist aber insbesondere die Stäbchen mit
dem wir das Essen sind übelst praktisch
war da keiner dabei also ich finde
gerade so die da sind keine dritte das
ist die einzige Stäbchen die wir haben
eigentlich so viele Finger tut ne habt
ihr das in Japan vergessen
Nigiri die sind FIFA sprechen aus sie
sind extrem gut aus muss man sagen sieht
einfach edel aus dann ich weiß nicht wie
das in Köln ist aber so die Sojasoße so
zu bekommen ist auch immer in die
Kartoffeln müssen
so genau das ist das ich weiß nicht das
selbst abgefüllt das sieht zumindest so
aus ne erste Eindruck nachdem er aus
Japan wieder gekommen seid was sagt ihr
dieses Sushi so was findest du auf jeden
Fall nicht in Japan also es ist kein
Dingen ja wir müssen mal ganz kurz
darüber reden das müssen wir jetzt hier
einfach offen und ehrlich sagen nee
sondern in die Bewertung laufen
natürlich viele Sachen mit rein
Lieferung die ist das alles und ich
glaube geschmacklich können die beiden
auf jeden Fall bewerten nämlich da mal
raus
aber eine falsche Beschwerden heute
diese Mission dass wir die richtig
erraten erfolgreich abschließen okay ich
bin gespannt Lukas ich lasse dir den
Anfang der hochwertige Sushi hat Wasabi
direkt unterm boah aber das ich weiß das
was du meinst aber das habe ich bei
liefer Sushi noch nie gesehen dass die
Wasabi drunter haben ja als er sein
können dass Du 9,4 das hat ich nehme
einfach mal was mich hier an lacht das
ist so eine Rolle Thunfisch vielleicht
oder ist es lach das lag sehr auch ein
bisschen gegart ist dann Avocado außen
frittiert Avocado ist auf jeden Fall
schon ein bisschen gereift ne sage ich
mal hier rein Jungs glaube es ist aber
sehr schwer zu erraten bei einem
frittierten Sushi wie die Qualität ist
oder wegen hier Leute
Hunger und es hat auf jeden Fall schon
mal geil geschmeckt so viel gesagt was
sagt ihr zu dem äh Nigiri es war jetzt
nicht so nice zu sagen Fischqualität war
auf jeden Fall gut aber der Reis war
einfach komplett überkocht ist einfach
nur Matchball gewesen aber trotzdem muss
man sagen ich glaube die Fisch Qualität
sah so ein bisschen nach fansi aus und
zwar sagen und könnt mir schon
vorstellen dass es mehr so eins von den
oberen beiden ist garantiert gehe ich
mit dir safe eines der oberen beiden
aber was für eins es ist kann ich noch
nicht genau sagen also ich würde jetzt
einfach aus meinem Kopf in mein
Gedächtnis würde ich das auf jeden Fall
auf die mittlere Position setzen weil
ich denke es geht noch deutlich besser
es hat sich angefühlt als würde ich
Milchreis essen ohne Zucker also auch
die Qualität von Nigiri könnte auch sage
ich ehrlich von meiner Erfahrung so als
Sushi Besteller in Köln könnte auch die
Nummer 1 sein aber ich gehe mit euch wir
machen die mittlere 8,2 fürs erste Sushi
vor allem wegen der Expertise der Jungs
Reis bisschen überkocht Fischqualität
gut es ist noch Luft nach oben mach
nochmal sicher zu gehen sagen wir mal
das ist das mittlere oder ja einfach
schauen
kannst du uns eine Sirene geben Erik
oben rechts und damit sind wir wieder da
Leute
unglaublich dass das schlechteste Sushi
%. ja wir haben wieder die Fische auf
jeden Fall ne hast du uns auf jeden Fall
reingerutschen kann bei der ganzen Sache
ist Erik hast du nur bei Sushi
Lieferanten bestellt oder bieten ich
auch noch andere Sachen an die haben
alle schon Sushi als Spezialität also
was man schon mal sagen kann ist es Sie
es sieht deutlich trockener aus es
glänzt nicht so die anrichtungen da ist
nicht so viel Mühe drin auch der Tuner
hier drüben ne der hat schon fast schon
so eine raue angetrocknete Oberfläche
und ich muss euch sagen ich habe das
Gefühl ich habe gerade eine Nase
bekommen davon die riecht jetzt auch
nicht so Todes fresh ich würde ohne
probieren setzt sich das auf 7,4 ich
würde erst probieren und dann meinen
Mann auch sehr dunkel auseinander
okay ähm was willst du probieren Lukas
diese Makrele will
du max
mein auch Gefühl schickt mich ich weiß
es ist kein gutes Zeichen
ich habe nicht so große Erwartungen aber
ich nehme hier mal den tun aber ich
hatte gerade eben auch Tuner
minimal ist der Sushi Reis auf jeden
Fall besser als bei dem vorigen weiß ich
nicht warum weil es ein bisschen
körniger aber ich würde persönlich hier
jetzt sofort sagen dass 7,4 also ich
lege meine beiden Hände dafür ins Feuer
dass die 74 ist ich finde der Tuner den
ich gerade hatte sehr Fische geschmeckt
ich habe kein gutes Gefühl
also auch von der Präsentation gerade
nachdem man das andere gesehen hat muss
ich sagen dass sie sie sind die letzte
Frage die ich habe sind die preislich
sehr weit auseinander alle oder ziemlich
ähnlich 3-4 Euro Unterschied dann bin
ich bei 7,4 für dieses Sushi wir sehen
halt auf jeden Fall preislich bei den
günstigsten selbst bei den günstigsten
setzen aber kann sein dass der Sohn fern
Preis hat dass er vielleicht trotzdem
besser ist kompliziert bin ich finde die
Reis Qualität ist auch nicht gigantisch
also es kann riesiger Unterschied ne
aber auch nicht so besonders gut und der
Fisch war sketchi das für uns alle auf
jeden Fall die 7,4 zu großer Unterschied
zum ersten jetzt bin ich sehr gespannt
auf das dritte wenn ich glaube das kann
alles durcheinander werfen wir
entscheiden jetzt und später haben wir
einen Job wir dürfen noch einmal
tauschen okay
7,4 ist okay
also wir haben auf jeden Fall eine
Variationen immer gehabt ne wir hatten
einmal crunchy einmal nur klassisches
Sushi und das hier ist auch eher wieder
tendenziell klassisch wir haben wieder
Makrele Butterfisch Tuner Zacke boah das
ist schwierig denn ich habe ein Gefühl
ich habe ein Gefühl ich habe ein Gefühl
der Geschmack wird uns recht geben oder
sagen ihr wart komplett falsch optisch
würde ich das in der Mitte einordnen das
ist eigentlich krass ne ich hätte bei
allen dreien beim ersten hätte ich
gesagt sieht krass aus den zweiten habe
ich gesagt es aus da würde ich sagen
genau in der Mitte von beiden ich auch
aber finde ich krass hat man schon so
eine starke Meinung das zeigt wie viel
doch so Anrichte und Optik beim Essen
wert ist ja und ich muss auch mal
ehrlich sagen egal ob wir jetzt richtig
oder falsch liegen Leute ihr könnt jetzt
auf jeden Fall auch mal abstimmen in den
Kommentaren welches für euch erster
zweiter dritter Platz ist ganz genau und
wichtig ist natürlich auch klar wir
bewerten Essen Orten ist irgendwie ein
aber wir haben von vor jedem Essen
Wertschätzung so ich hatte noch keinen
Tag gemacht hier das muss ich probieren
oh hä das ist hier das ist ja Geist habe
ich noch nie gesehen oben DAX unten
wahrscheinlich Butterfisch aber ist das
bei allen so oder haben die in eine
Rolle beides gewollt ja eine Rolle
beides gerollt ich bin doch ehrlich ich
habe das auch noch nicht wirklich
gesehen mit Paprika und dann vielleicht
so ja Frischkäse ist unter dem Lachs
oben die Sache ist die Eriks hat uns auf
jeden Fall nicht einfach gemacht und was
auch ein Ding ist ich war mir bisher
immer tot sicher mit meiner Bewertung
und sie hat nie gestimmt in diesem
Format okay da oder ich glaube ich würde
sogar wirklich wieder auf diesen Lachs
gehen ich muss halt ehrlich sagen ist
auch gar nicht böse gemeint aber den
Reis fand ich jetzt bei allen dreien
nicht überwältigen der Fisch war für
mich immer noch beim ersten am besten
aber trotzdem noch nicht sicher auf gar
keinen Fall auf die eins wird ja auch
sagen ich bin auch eher zwischen ist das
doch das letzte aber mein Bauchgefühl
sagt er nicht wir haben wir sie noch mal
alle ich finde es spricht auch schon ein
bisschen Bände was wie viel gegessen
wurde also klar das war das erste bei
dem hatten wir am meisten Hunger die
anderen beiden werden wir später noch
die zionieren ich habe eine Frage auf
jeden Fall war meistens das
bestbewerteste dann auch das
hochwertigste bzw teuerste nein leider
nicht leider nicht also im Prinzip habe
ich mir jedes mal gedacht hey wie kann
das sein wir können auch komplett
auseinander genommen werden aber heute
habe ich einen sehr sehr gutes Gefühl
wenn wir noch eine Sache machen ihr
wisst vielleicht was ich noch vorhabe du
bist auf jeden Fall das auf die eins
nehmen würde ich machen ja aber ich
finde alleine guck mal hier so die
Schnittkanten vom Reis ne der hier ist
so sauber geschnitten das hier ist 100 %
letzter müssen wir die zwei noch
tauschen sind wir uns alleine oder ja
oder würdest du sagen dass das
vielleicht das beste war sogar tauschen
wir kommen haben wir endlich recht mit
unserer Bewertung sehen wir uns
eigentlich oder das stimmt du kannst
okay okay
[Musik]
lyric erlöse uns die erste Bewertung 7,4
die getroffen hat ist leider nicht
richtig oh mein Gott oh mein gott ich
hasse dieses Format
schön dass ihr bei der
letzten Format dabei war heute noch
irgendwas sagen wollten beenden nicht
schaffen dann ist unmöglich das zu
schaffen wow wow wow wow kann das nicht
stimmt das Sushi sorry aber das war das
ist keins dass wir getauscht haben auf
jeden Fall das haben wir auf jeden Fall
darauf
zu bleiben den Läden gegenüber sagen
auch einfach keine Namen so 7,4 ist
eigentlich 8,2 ich habe kein Platz mehr
für Ausreden ich weiß aber da kommt
Lieferung da kommt alles rein okay aber
das ist nicht das stimmt nicht auf auf
keinen Fall das stimmt nicht lügen
jetzt die Frage seid ihr wenigstens mit
den anderen beiden richtig ja
wir sind komplett falsch wie wir sind
9,4 ist eigentlich 7,4 und das ist 9,4
okay und das das Liebling ist das
7,5
diese
Restaurants aber ich verstehe einfach
gar nichts mehr also no joke ich das
macht keinen Sinn es macht mich wirklich
mittlerweile sauer dieses Format wir
haben das doch so schlau hergeleitet das
hat alles Sinn gemacht
[Musik]
das hier sind also die finalen
Bewertungen ist nicht mehr so viel übrig
teilweise aber ich hätte niemals damit
gerechnet schreibt man gerne in die
Kommentare ob ihr es richtig erraten
habt vielleicht fühlt ihr auch mit uns
und hat genauso geraten jedenfall vielen
Dank dass ihr dabei wart Jungs danke
Lukas ihr müsst unbedingt ganz bald auf
Lukas Kanal vorbeischauen für eine Kebab
Land Dokumentation wird sehr wild bei
Randy müsste sowieso vorbeischauen
deshalb mach's gut bis dahin ciao
okay jetzt reden wir noch mal wirklich
darüber okay ohne